[Música]
[Aplausos]
grande
[Música]
wang
etiqueta estereotipo discriminación
la idea es romper muros pero sabes cómo
construimos esos muros
mejor aún como eliminamos las divisiones
que son la expresión de estos muros de
lo que tú eres y lo que soy yo
hasta donde tu visión es verdad y la mía
es adecuada
me vas a decir que es la cultura me vas
a decir que son las percepciones no vas
a decir que es la educación
y que ese es un conjunto de todo qué
pasa cuando una broma
es el reflejo de la construcción de los
muros que hoy nos dividen
como un meme es muy divertido pero sabes
el alcance que esto puede tener
sabes lo que hay detrás de una broma que
parece inofensiva
hoy vengo a pedirte
yo como tú me reía de los memes me
parecían bromas de lo más inofensivas yo
como tú entendí el mundo en categorías y
muchas veces hasta en estereotipos ya
compartimentos inmediatos para poder
procesar toda la información que
recibimos todos los días
meter en categorías y hacerlo tan rápido
como expuesto estás a los fenómenos en
el mundo pero fue después de unos meses
de estar en medio oriente que me di
cuenta del daño que esto puede hacer y
me dije para
no más
desde línea siempre estoy expuesta a
mucha información y mamá me enseñó que
el mundo viene sin filtros y que todo es
relativo a lo que uno entiende por
verdad comenzó a generar categorías esto
lo conozco es bueno y luego está lo
demás
recuerdo que tenía unos 10 o 11 años
cuando me llevó a ver mi primer
documental sobre la guerra de bosnia en
la ex yugoslavia
cuando le dijeron que no podía entrar
porque era muy fuerte para mi edad su
respuesta fue y los niños que la viven
no es fuerte para ellos crecí entonces
entre noticias colocando etiquetas de
guerras justas injustas de conflictos
constantes y me preguntará por qué y la
respuesta era siempre la misma porque no
se entienden
fue entonces que comencé con esta locura
por entender convencido de que si se
podía las culturas y su diversidad
pronto se volvieron en mi fascinación
después de algunos años ya me encontraba
en yemen medio diente realizando un
proyecto de investigación llegué después
de haber estudiado la región de haber
leído libros artículos revistas tratados
vaya de haber visto textos no por lo que
yo quería firmemente que no tiene ningún
impedimento para conectar y entender la
cultura de la región y no podía estar
más equivocada
yo con muchísimos académicos que ahí se
encontraban estaba lista permitir un
juicio rápido para ver cuánto de lo que
yo creía entender entraba en lo típico
entraba en lo que alguna vez escuché en
una tez la imagen que te da una sola
historia si es exactamente lo que estás
pensando cuando entraba en el
estereotipo
fue hasta que conocí a fátima una mujer
de saná la capital
y llegué por supuesto con una etiqueta
típica que se utiliza para todas las
mujeres de la región oye si cubren
porque las obligan es triste es
retrógrada es el reflejo de una sociedad
misógino y machista inclusive me atreví
a decirle pobre si ustedes
ella me miró sorprendida no era la
primera vez que escuchaba algo así
seguramente ustedes tampoco y me dijo
déjame te cuento cómo es que yo elegí a
mi esposo
conocí a bashir me contaba desde la
escuela
yo sabía quién era yo sabía lo que
pensaba me encantaba su punto de vista
cuando supe que su mamá iría a la
próxima fiesta me dije tengo que estar
ahí hay que saber que las fiestas en
yemen se dividen entre hombres y mujeres
como muchas cosas de la sociedad en
yemen pero eso es no es tema de esta
plática en la fiesta me dijo busquen
verme de lo más linda posible para que
su mamá me notará y lo hizo conectamos
súper bien nos llevamos fantásticamente
con ella y sus hermanas esto es muy
importante porque son las mujeres las
que eligen a la esposa de sus hijos
varones
al terminar la fiesta me dijo cumples
con todas las características que mi
hijo busca para casarse al poco tiempo y
estaban comprometidos el compromiso dura
de seis meses hasta un año inclusive más
durante este tiempo
ahora él me conoce a mí me decía jamás
bebé pero conoce lo importante cuando sé
lo que pienso lo que me hace reír cuáles
son mis sueños
el último día de la boda estaba listo
para verme imagínense ustedes que van a
ver por primera vez en su vida a la
mujer que tanto aman
fátima me afirmo con seguridad
mi matrimonio durará lo que dure la vida
porque está enamorado de quien soy y no
de cómo me ve
y esta es una de las razones por las
cuales yo elijo utilizar el mecano
hasta la fecha ellos siguen juntos yo
también conocí a mi esposo a un
estudiante estadounidense
y recuerdo que cuando nos casamos me
dijeron estás consciente de que tu
matrimonio te va a durar lo que te dure
la juventud
antes de fátima me hubiera tomado esto
mal
pero para entonces entendí no
necesariamente comparto su visión pero
tampoco voy a emitir un juicio de está
bien o está mal simplemente entendí
que para poder conectar con estas
personas hay que entenderlo desde su
perspectiva desde su centro está aquí
donde podemos conectarnos donde podemos
construir un vínculo pero cómo hacerlo
si el mundo va tan rápido
y cómo podemos conectar
entonces lo supe no lo hacemos y es así
como desarrollamos nuestras divisiones
nuestras categorías inmediatas es así
como construimos los muros que hoy nos
dividen
pero no puedo ser la única que haya
visto esto y recordé entonces que la
mejor manera de enmarcar todo este
debate que tanto se ha analizado es
hablar de la cultura como la
conceptualizamos como miramos a una
sociedad e identificamos las
características que la definen las
prácticas que la unen
pero por qué es tan importante la
cultura muchos académicos han dedicado
gran parte de su vida al estudio de ella
el doctor jose esta vez hizo esta misma
pregunta y desarrolló toda una teoría en
torno a ella planteando un modelo de
círculos donde en el centro ponía los
valores nacionales y alrededor las
prácticas culturales y aunque este
modelo está pensado para entender a la
cultura en sí misma es extraordinario
para entender cómo es que nosotros
desarrollamos nuestras categorías si lo
extendemos para poner en el círculo
valores fundamentales humanos valores
presentes en todas las sociedades a
través de toda la línea del tiempo
histórica valores como la vida la
autodeterminación la libertad de
elección el acceso a un nivel sostenible
de vida
pero entender que la expresión de estos
valores se va a filtrar y conceptualizar
alrededor de círculos que vienen
extendidos dentro de estos valores por
ejemplo prácticas usos y costumbres
religión
contexto histórico y geográfico estatus
económico educación cultura civil
interacción global cuántos y cuán
amplios sean estos círculos depende de
cada una de las personas no
necesariamente de la generalidad de una
cultura sino de la experiencia de cada
individuo
tomemos por ejemplo el valor nos digamos
la libertad de elección
y esta se va a filtrar de tal suerte que
lo que va a ser diferente entre el
fátima y yo va a ser la expresión de
este valor digamos lo que elegimos
vestir
esto me llevó a reconocer lo que ha sido
el rector de mi vida
-nosotros discriminamos lo que no
conocemos no nosotros discriminamos lo
que no entendemos
y me van a decir esto estudio ya se
hablaba muchísimas veces esto ya lo
sabíamos
nosotros somos abiertos informados vamos
a textos nosotros no discriminamos pero
si lo hacemos como
la doctora kate a una de las directoras
de la 'play' nos platica que todas las
personas discriminan por un conjunto
complejo de factores incluye la historia
las prácticas socioculturales las
fuerzas económicas las tendencias
sociales la influencia de las creencias
de tu comunidad y de tu familia
prácticamente nuestros círculos y
extendidos aquí es donde se origina la
discriminación las tensiones sociales
cuando estos círculos chocan generando
una interacción prejuiciosa es decir yo
estoy bien tú mal déjame te explico cómo
no
ok vamos a borrarlo
tampoco porque así funciona nuestro
cerebro así es como nosotros
desarrollamos las categorías que nos
ayudan a entender este mundo sin filtros
entonces viene una pregunta obligada
cada categoría es discriminación no
tampoco pero hay una línea delgada muy
delgada la inmediatez
cuando tus categorías se vuelven
inmediatas
se tornan en etiquetas
y entonces en estereotipos
y fácilmente en discriminación
hay un límite en todo inclusive los
memes
lo peligroso de esto es cuando se vuelve
natural
etiqueta estereotipo discriminación
y qué pasa si las personas que se
manejan así fueran maestros
fueron policías
o fueran doctores
y se dirigieron a empresas
o estuvieron al frente de un país
qué pasa cuando el peligro
es la naturalidad
segura verde algo
se vuelve tangible
y es por eso que hoy vengo a pedirte
vivimos en un mundo rápido sí pero como
siempre le digo a mis alumnos se vale
decir eso no lo sé antes emitir un
juicio antes de imponer tu verdad antes
de hablar de lo que conocemos pero no
entendemos porque hoy no hay que
entenderlo todo porque efectivamente
vivimos en un mundo de inmediatez pero
hoy también vivimos en un mundo en el
que tú tienes el poder de elegir en qué
momento te dices
muchísimas gracias
[Música]